bei diesen aufnahmen aus der
französischen stadt grenoble bleibt
einem fast das herz stehen
aus dem fenster im dritten stock dringt
dichter schwarzer rauch die wohnung
steht in flammen
eine person im inneren hält ein kind aus
dem fenster und lässt kürzlich los eine
kleine menschengruppe fängt das kind
unten auf kurze zeit später wird ein
zweites kind fallen gelassen
die aktion ging gerade noch mal gut die
beiden kinder drei und zehn jahre alt
bleiben unverletzt
die zwei männer die die kinder gerettet
haben kommen mit gebrochenen unterarm
ins krankenhaus
laut medienberichten wurden bei dem
feuer 17 menschen verletzt
etwa 40 feuerwehrleute waren im einsatz
die brandursache ist unklar
unglaubliche bilder und genau darüber
möchte ich jetzt noch etwas mehr
sprechen mit harten und sie erst mal
live zugeschaltet und vizepräsident des
weltverbandes chf guten morgen herr
chips wir haben es gerade gesehen die
kinder boden aus dem dritten stock
eingelassen um sie zu retten wurden
unten gottseidank aufgefangen für wie
gefährlich haben sie aber diese aktion
gehalten
guten morgen zusammen was die bilder
haben mich richtig ansetzt und ich halte
sie für sehr gefährlich
ich verstehe es aber auch es ist glaube
ich der letzte ausweg für den bewohner
gewesen seine kinder zu retten aber
ungemein gefährlich und das geht nicht
immer so gut aus wieder wie verhalte ich
mich dann am besten wenn tatsächlich
vorher in meiner wohnung aus er sich
ausbreitet und im schlimmsten fall die
wohnungstür verbarrikadiert man nicht
mehr rauskommt also wir sehen hier in
dem film dass es ein sehr
fortgeschrittene wohnungsbrand ist am
besten man fängt viel früher an indem
man rauchmelder installiert damit man so
früh wie möglich alarmiert wird wenn es
selber in der wohnung brennt dann die
wohnung so schnell wie möglich verlassen
wenn kann man vielleicht noch ein
löschversuch unternehmer besser die
wohnung verlassen die feuerwehr
informieren nachbarn informieren und
dann raus wenn man gar nicht mehr
rauskommt tief am boden versuchen zum
ausgang sich zu bewegen am boden ist die
luft noch am besten
und dann versuchen rauszukommen wenn wir
jetzt noch mal diese bilder sehen wie
die kinder unten aufgefangen werden
man kennt das auch manchmal aussehen
wenn die feuerwehr selber unten dann
versucht menschen aufzufangen wie wie
schwierig ist das überhaupt für retter
unten dann kinder auffangen zu können
wie schwer muss man sich das vorstellen
das eine kind drei das andere schon zehn
jahre alt also auch relativ groß schon
also der sprung ins sprungpolster ist
immer der letzte ausweg auch für die
feuerwehr dann geht nichts anderes mehr
man muss das sprungpolster in stellung
bringen die person muss so lange warten
bis es dann richtig steht und dann muss
auch die person auch richtig da rein
springen das ist nochmal der allerletzte
ausweg und wir gehen dabei auch immer
das risiko ein dass menschen verletzt
werden